This is how it started.
Another exciting evening at 53 Blackwood Road.
Hi, Julia.
How are you?
Yeah, sure.
When's your birthday?
The 4th of August.
That's Leo.
You're a lion.
What's wrong?
Nothing.
What about you?
My birthday's the 16th of March.
I'm a Pisces.
A fish.
What's the horoscope sign for this month?
May?
The first part is Taurus.
The bull.
So, Jane's a bull.
Is Jane's birthday this month?
When?
The 13th.
The 13th of May?
But it's the 11th of May today!
That's in two days.
Are you sure?
That's what she said.
Did you hear?
No.
It's Jane's birthday on Saturday.
Why don't we have a party?
In two days?
Yeah.
A surprise party.
Good idea.
Right.
How many people?
Just the four of us.
A meal, a cake, something to drink, presents.
Okay, let's make a shopping list.